[Musique]
je prends le cannabis parce que j'aime
cannabis et je prends aussi parce que
j'ai besoin d'eux pour sentir bien pour
prendre le focus
[Musique]
il faut et jessica sont des influences
euse et se considère les nouveaux
visages de l'industrie du cannabis sur
les réseaux sociaux
instagram en tête des neiges chef de now
and i est aussi un des nouveaux visages
du cannabis comme influences euse elle
teste des produits de l'industrie et
influença à les auteurs et les personnes
qui vraiment part à propos de cannabis
chez les femmes
[Musique]
faire la promotion du cannabis c'est
interdit par la loi qui sanctionne les
infractions par des peines de prison et
des amendes
pourtant l'un des objectifs de ces
influenceurs c'est de générer des
revenus de l'industrie du cannabis se
faire payer pour du placement de
produits des contrats de publicité ou
même des commissions sur les tests de
produits comme annie par exemple mais
présentait le cannabis d'une façon
attirante presque glamour est ce légal
pour l'instant la loi n'a pas encore été
vraiment mise à l'épreuve
pour moi il faut que je sois certaine
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est comme
éducation information à quelque chose
qui donne du qualité mais faut voir
[Musique]
pour elle c'est un mode de vie et ils en
sont fiers
pas tout le monde qui consomment le
cannabis c'est pour être jeune et il ya
beaucoup de monde qui veut juste prendre
le cannabis pour pour le bien-être pour
la créativité
la mission de ces nouveaux visages c'est
de féminiser et surtout de chasser
l'image péjorative du fumeur de potes et
pour jessica cette mission-là concerne
particulièrement
[Musique]
chn en tout cas les influences euse se
défendre de faire l'apologie du cannabis
[Musique]
pour annie jessica et jennyfer rien
n'empêche que cette mission d'éducation
sociale passe aussi par leurs
affirmations de la féminité et du
plaisir de partager leur passion pour
leurs plantes vertes préféré je vois les
les émissions de télé comme sex naceri
et j'imagine mois jusqu'aux mains kerry
brescia mais au lieu de boire des
martinis j'ai fait mon petit cannabis ce
qu'elles font d'ailleurs lorsqu'elle se
retrouve ensemble au sein de la
communauté grandissante d'un flux en sus
du cannabis le cannabis un mode de vie
en tout cas pour ces influences euse sur
les réseaux sociaux comme instagram la
ligne reste mince entre l' influence la
promotion déguisée et la responsabilité
sociale
mais pour ces nouveaux visages du
cannabis des promesses et les espoirs de
revenus d'une manière ou d'une autre en
valent la chandelle
[Musique]